réduire sa production pour faire face à
la chute des ventes depuis le début du
confinement maxime ancelin a dû diviser
par deux le nombre de fromages qui
produisait chaque jour aujourd'hui on a
fabriqué ici chariot en temps habituel
on aurait dû être en produits vous avez
bien ça aurait représenté 20 des
chariots jusqu'à moi et on va dire les
fromages les plus affinée d'habitude
réservé aux connaisseurs partent à la
poubelle
les marchés sont interdits en ce moment
donc aucune vente sur ses produits la
veille avoir peut-être mille fromages
des 20% de la production jeter et
l'obligation de continuer à fabriquer
des fromages malgré des ventes freiner
en effet maxime en cela n'est pas membre
d'une coopérative laitière
il lui est formellement interdit de
jeter le lait pour éviter la
contamination des sols
alors pour produire moins cet éleveur
s'est résigné à sacrifier un tiers de
son cheptel compterait environ entre 100
et 150 bêtes on a vendu 25 vaches à peu
près et puis on a mis en tas rythmant
donc au repos environ 20 à 25 soit 6,1
de toute façon aujourd'hui si on n'avait
pas pris ces mesures là c'est sûr et
certain que à l'heure actuelle j'ai
traduit pas question en revanche de
supprimer des emplois ou d'opter pour le
chômage partiel pour le moment mais
difficile d'envisager un avenir à court
terme sans une aide de l'état
on fait tout pour avoir le maintien de
l'emploi parce qu'aujourd'hui je pars du
principe que 70 % de leur salaire pour
se doit pas être suffisant après si la
situation à devenir de plus en plus
critique qui n'a pas souhaité dans le
temps on sera obligé de prendre d'autres
mesures ça serait vraiment bien de
retirer les charges sociales durant la
durée du confinement
je pense que ça nous aiderait beaucoup
ça nous permettrait de pouvoir maintenir
les emplois plus longtemps et l'après
confinement inquiète tout autant la
crainte celle de la flambée des prix qui
pourrait entraîner une nouvelle baisse
des ventes